I just can't shake this feeling
something's off there's a very good
reason
director mace is never too far away from
that briefcase
[Music]
we need answers
agents of shield
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my episode 9 episode 10 promo video
I'm just combining those two things so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
episode 9 yet there is a new round of
the Hulkbuster giveaway going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
previous winners announced at the end of
the video so be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything so we'll start with episode 9
top 10 Easter eggs all that stuff then
I'll do the stuff in the promo for the
next episode for episode 10 so number 10
Ghost Rider and Eli Morrow are lost in
the dark dimension or whichever
dimension they've been pulling energy
from the way they're hinting is that
it's the hell of the Marvel Universe
the only thing that's keeping me from
saying that it's definitely the dark
dimension is the fact that the spirit of
vengence said there's no way that I'm
going back in what happens is is when
souls get pulled to the dark dimension
in co-opted by Dormammu they sort of get
turned into mindless ones they have like
one giant eye in the middle of their
face they sort of stop being people so
it's not like you can come back from
that so the other option is hell
Mephisto domain which actually has like
real souls that could potentially escape
it all goes into Ghost Rider's origin
story from the comics the Johnny Blaze
Ghost Rider who we know passed his
spirit of vengeance to this version of
Ghost Rider
so they're both stuck in that other
dimension for now but you have to
remember that Eli Morrow still infused
with all that energy they're both still
tied to the dark hold the dark hold is
still a very big MacGuffin this season
so it'll all come together by the season
finale meaning the Ghost Rider will be
back so number 9
Ghost Rider probably not coming back for
a little while just because the dark
hold is something that they're going for
but until dr. Radcliffe gets it in
things go completely sideways we
probably won't see Ghost Rider again
because you see the pitch now mad
scientist gets his hands on the dark
hold something terrible happens that
provides the opportunity for Ghost Rider
to come back number 8 ADA goes full
Ultron and open revolt and it's the
start of max 80s robot uprising movie
jokes
so he made a sick burn on Terminator
Salvation like oh we're gonna make him
watch all the Terminator movies even Sal
I guess that depends on how bad you
think that one was
there's the Maximum Overdrive joke when
the Quinjet starts going after them that
was actually a Stephen King book but
it's about cards that come alive and
start chasing people down to kill them
and then a chopping mall joke at the
very end which is like a b-movie about a
bunch of robots Adam all you can imagine
killing everybody pretty much everybody
in the episode got their robot uprising
joke but Mac had all the good movie
references number seven BJ nadir the
inhuman in the cocoon wakes up we learn
he's the senator's brother and we get
their backstory using flashbacks to the
MCU we learned that they lived in New
York and their mother was killed during
the shatori invasion so the senator
starts talking about a promise that they
made each other that if either one of
them was compromised by an alien virus
that they would take care you know kill
the other person alike put them down
before the affliction took them so you
learned why she hates Inhumans so much
because she equates that with her
mother's death this big disaster aliens
taking over she's like we got to get rid
of them she really doesn't know what's
going on the Inhumans are kind of like
an offshoot of humanity they have
dormant genes that are awakened so
becoming an inhuman is sort of like
evolving just like VJ goes through a
couple of different evolutions of the
episode but number six the director is
forcing Daisy to work with him stay
close because of the very public thing
that happened with the Ghost Rider
incident the director himself is still
very mysterious he's the patriot from
the comics who took up the mantle of
Captain America next week's episode is
actually called the Patriots was
actually gonna explain some of the
secrets that he's keeping because right
now it seems like he's an inhuman but
he's not an inhuman in the comics and he
never got the Super Soldier Serum so he
just took up the mantle of Captain
America but he was still a normal person
but really the real drama is the may
life model decoy and what she's going to
do because she seems really benign she's
just being used as this tool to get her
hands on the Darkhold
number five ADA's full-blown Terminator
assault to get the dark hold on the
shield base so this was
so greatly she eventually gets her hands
on the Darkhold
she gives this big speech about the
things that the dark hold has revealed
to her it revealed desire it revealed
all these emotions so it's this very
Pinocchio no strings on me Ultron type
situation but just as she's about to
leave
doors open boom Matt gets her with the
shotgun axe it was a great way to go
down just chop that head right off but
because of the twist at the end you have
to wonder whether or not she actually
acquired human emotion because dr.
Radcliffe is treating these life model
decoys is sort of disposable toys like
he just makes as many as he wants so
we'll see if that doesn't bite him in
the ass by the end number four the
senator tries to kill her brother using
the watchdog's his powers activate we
learned he has a version of SuperSpeed
but he's not really based on any of the
Inhumans from the comics that you know
remains to be seen
he's going through a second evolution so
that might change him into something a
little more familiar but he himself is
someone that's original to the TV show
he's not named after a comic book
character number three we learned the
senator is either working with the
watchdog's or working for them their
boss is someone named the superior who
they keep using male pronouns to
describe so it sounds like a man and it
sounds like based on the set up it's
gonna be either someone that we've met
before
on the TV show some villain will reveal
himself like oh my god I can't believe
it was that person or it's gonna be a
big comic book character but there is
somebody from Marvel Comics history
named John Gallagher whose alias is
superior so he might be the person on
agents of shield just like another big
boss that they haven't revealed yet you
know you have like your Darth Vader
reveal then eventually you find that the
Emperor is really behind it all so this
is like a very Star Wars type reveal so
we'll meet him eventually but they're
just setting him up is this really
mysterious powerful person but number
two dr. Radcliffe reveals he was behind
everything he orchestrated ADA's actions
making you wonder if she actually really
was sentient if she was being honest
when she said the Darkhold showed her
all those emotion
but here's the thing that I like the
actor John Hannah is playing him as this
crazy mad scientist he's not evil he
wants to help humanity so in a very
classic mad scientist twist
he's just overreaching like he just
doesn't care what the consequences are
he's not thinking about how it might go
sideways he's just thinking of the
amazing things that they'll be able to
do with the Darkhold
which means that it is going to blow up
in everyone's faces in the best possible
way it's gonna be so WTF it'll be great
if you thought eli morrow had crazy
plans for the Darkhold what dr.
Radcliffe has planned is way bigger he
like he's trying to evolve Humanity in
the same way that the Terrigen mists
evolve humanity but we know the Darkhold
itself was created by an elder god -
thought to sort of troll anyone that was
brave enough to read it so he really
just trying to create chaos but it
really does have the knowledge of the
universe inside it so if you could
control it like if you were dr. strange
you might actually be able to make use
of it but you can just bet that nobody
on this show is gonna be able to handle
whatever it is they pull out of the dark
hole is always gonna blow up in their
faces and I did like Coulson's teas that
they were taking the dark hold to
someone that was capable of disposing of
it they were sort of teasing dr. strange
somebody with magical abilities that
could contain the dark hold because it
can't be destroyed you can only hope to
contain it number one WTF of course is
Vijay nadir going through his second
evolution so he goes into the cocoon
meanie that's gonna heal him he'll
emerge and it'll probably be something
like when Quicksilver from the comics
took in the chair gin mist so when a
normal person with inhuman DNA takes in
the Terrigen mist it unlocks their
abilities they gain some special power
but when someone already has powers like
somebody with the X gene or you know
just somebody who's a metahuman takes in
the Terrigen mist they get powers that
are way off the charts crazy
they might choose to use him in a
Ulysses Marvel Civil War to type way so
during Civil War - Ulysses is a new
inhuman that seems like he has the
ability to predict the future but it
continued
to evolve like he gets more and more
powerful until he can predict the future
in the entire multiverse so people get
really confused he starts saying oh
these things are gonna happen he shows
them visions of what might happen but it
turns out that those are things that
might happen in other realities so he
becomes so powerful that the cosmic
entity eternity comes down and welcomes
him to the fold and he becomes a cosmic
entity himself like that's how powerful
he gets so that also might be what's
happening with the v-j character but you
guys can let me know what do you think
is gonna happen when Vijay comes out of
that cocoon how powerful do you think
he's going to be next big thing the
promo for the next episode so this is
all about the Patriots back story in the
comics he was the third version of
Captain America they've teased that he
might get to use Captain America shield
on the TV show but like the clip says
general Talbot is suspicious of him
there's a reason he always travels with
that briefcase so we're gonna learn what
that is we're gonna learn how he got his
powers congratulations to this week's
Hulkbuster giveaway aravinda shock
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video on ounce the
winner when I post my next agents of
shield video next week next week will be
just like normal because all the other
shows that would normally air on Tuesday
aren't back for like another two weeks
so next shield video will come next
Wednesday big news Spiderman was just
confirmed for Avengers infinity war we
have an idea of what the big roster is
going to be so I'll do a video for that
tonight there's also some Star Wars
Episode 8 plot teasers that the director
was dropping so that'll be next after
spider-man will you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn all
about thor ragnarok Avengers infinity
war in the death of the Marvel Universe
and you can click here to learn all
about why everyone's freaking out about
the Batman
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight